[Music]
today's question comes from chris and
maryland
i use credit cards for their rewards
i look at getting them
wait i look at it like getting revenge
on the credit card companies for all the
money that i paid them an interest so
long before i started being responsible
they
had no problem charging me 25 interest
and missed fee and late fees if i missed
a payment so now i get all the rewards
and i can make up for the money that
they got out of me
if i had paid them five thousand dollars
in interest over the years and collected
more of that in rewards i come out ahead
what do you think about this mindset
chris listen they're winning in life
like
like like do you see their buildings do
you see the banks buildings around like
you're not you're not getting them like
you're five thousand dollars you think
it's making a dent
uh in the side of them and it's just not
and so
for me let me just tell you
study after study has been proven that
you spend more when you spend with
credit cards okay that's just a fact
it's 12 to 18
or more
according to dun and bradstreet that was
done just a few years ago that study so
you're going to spend more with credit
cards even if you think i'm going to get
them with the rewards you're spending
more
period
so you're getting the rewards for
spending more money
versus saying hey i'm just going to pay
for what i want with cash with my debit
card
and then whatever reward i was going to
get from the credit card company
i'm probably going to say i'm going to
have saved because i use my own money
that amount or even more to make up my
own rewards over here so so for me i
just know you end up spending more i
also know that your perspective when you
use credit cards even if you say you pay
them off every month which a new study
came out that up to they said almost 28
of americans are the only ones that
actually pay off their balance in full
every month so majority of people do not
they carry a balance
but that mindset of well if i paid off
every month but still even if you do
okay even if you do pay yourself every
month there is still this idea that at
the end of the month and you pay that
bill you are still paying for things
that you have already experienced that
is foods you've already eaten movies
you've already seen vacations you've
already taken you are literally living
your life in a rear view mirror versus
if you said i'm actually going to just
when i spend money i'm going to spend my
own money and it's coming out of my bank
account in the moment and that's how i'm
going to live you end up living in the
present and even in the future because
when you budget you're looking ahead to
say hey what am i going to be doing
there and you're casting a vision you
have a plan going forward
versus continuing to look back and
that's what you do i had a friend who
was hardcore on this stuff uh for years
and we went out to dinner with them a
few months ago and he was like rachel i
gotta confess i got a southwest credit
card i was like it's i mean like i'm
like
like i'm not gonna yell at you like we
can we're still gonna be friends and go
to dinner and all of that you know uh
he's like i know i know but i just like
i need to tell you i was like that's
fine you don't have to tell me
well fast forward until um like two
weeks after that
we were talking uh with him and his wife
and us and he said because i actually
ended up cutting up that credit card i
told you i got and i was like oh really
he's like yeah i had it for about three
months
and he said and i realized
how much more i just i just spent
subconsciously like
we went to the athletic store and my
kids needed new jerseys
for the team and you know this
professional team that they're getting
jerseys for
and he's like and i found myself being
like oh we'll get the nicer ones yeah
cause it's only like you know 20 bucks
more it's not that big of a video here
go and he's like and i just ended up
subconsciously just just spending a
little bit more because the emotional
tie of not spending my own money was so
real and so true
and when you know it's your money coming
out of your account you just spend money
differently
and then the last thing i'll say it's
credit card rant man it
and some people are like oh that doesn't
bother me but it does bother me because
here's because because chris you're
getting these rewards
and all of this because of people who
have mismanaged their money people that
are mismanaging their money you're
benefiting from their mismanagement for
your own self and to me it's gross it's
a toxic environment it's a toxic
industry that i'm like no i want nothing
to do with it i'm good like i have a
debit card i've never had a credit card
i'm alive i'm breathing air and you can
still survive today and just spend your
own money and not even mess and play
with the game so to me i want nothing to
do with them so chris um i don't like
your mindset
you asked what did you think about your
mindset i don't like it i don't like it
there's my answer